[Music]
a few years ago you founded a company
that manufactures meatless burgers your
product is now sold in stores worldwide
but you've recently received awful news
three unrelated people in one city died
after eating your burgers the police
concluded that a criminal targeted your
brand injecting poison into your product
in at least two grocery stores the
culprit used an ultra fine instrument
that left no trace on the packaging
making it impossible to determine which
products were compromised your burgers
were immediately removed from the two
stores where the victims bought them the
deaths are headline news the killer is
still at large
and sales have plummeted you must
quickly develop a strategy to deal with
the crisis your team comes up with three
options one do nothing to pull the
products from grocery stores citywide
and destroy them or three pull and
destroy the product worldwide which do
you choose your company lawyer explains
that a recall is not required by law
because the criminal is fully
responsible she recommends the first
option doing nothing because recalling
the product could look like an admission
of fault but is that the most ethical
strategy to gauge the ethicality of each
choice you could perform a stakeholder
analysis this would allow you to weigh
the interests of some key stakeholders
investors employees and customers
against one another with the first
option your advisors project that the
crisis will eventually blow over
sales will then improve but probably
stay below prior levels because of
damage to the brand as a result you'll
have to layoff some employees and
investors will suffer minor losses but
more customers could die if the killer
poisoned packages elsewhere
the second option is expensive in the
short term and will require greater
employee layoffs and additional
financial loss to investors but this
option is safer for customers in the
city and could create enough trust that
sales will eventually rebound the third
option is the most expensive in the
short term and will require significant
employee layoffs and investor losses
though you have no evidence that these
crimes are an international threat this
option provides the greatest customer
protection given the conflict between
the interests of your customers versus
those of your investors and employees
which strategy is the most ethical to
make this decision you could consider
these tests first is the utilitarian
test utilitarianism is a philosophy
concerned with maximizing the greatest
amount of good for the greatest number
of people what would be the impact of
each option on these terms second is the
family test how would you feel
explaining your decision to your family
third is the newspaper test how would
you feel reading about it on the front
page of the local newspaper and finally
you could use the mentor test if someone
you admire were making this decision
what would they do
Johnson and Johnson's CEO James Burke
faced a similar challenge in 1982 after
a criminal added the poison cyanide two
bottles of Tylenol in Chicago seven
people died and sales dropped industry
analysts said the company was done for
in response
Burke decided to pull tylenol from all
shelves worldwide citing customer safety
as the company's highest priority
Johnson & Johnson recalled and destroyed
an estimated 32 million bottles of
Tylenol valued at 250 million in today's
dollars 1.5 million of the recalled
bottles were test
and three of them all from the Chicago
area were found to contain cyanide
Burke's decision helped the company
regain the trust of its customers and
product sales rebounded within a year
prompted by the tylenol murders Johnson
& Johnson became a leader in developing
tamper resistant packaging and the
government instituted stricter
regulations the killer meanwhile was
never caught
Burke's decision prevented further
deaths from the initial poisoning but
the federal government investigated
hundreds of copycat tampering incidents
involving other products in the
following weeks could these have been
prevented
with a different response was Burke
acting in the interest of the public or
of his company was this good ethics or
good marketing as with all ethical
dilemmas this has no clear right or
wrong answer and for your meatless
burger Empire the choice remains yours
would you sacrifice one person to save
five unpack this famous ethical dilemma
with our video on the trolley problem or
learn how the efforts of one scientist
at the FDA prevented a national health
crisis
[Music]